vous débarquez de l'autobus parce que
vous venez de Québec semble-t-il comme
un peu comme uber le noir vous voulez
pas déménager à Montréal il ressemble à
quoi elles sont Québec puis pourquoi ça
s'est attachement là à la capitale
nationale
on parle beaucoup de ça le son Québec
c'est quoi elles ont Québec je sais pas
je suis trop dedans on dirait que c'est
comme souvent ça c'est quoi son Québec
ben je sais pas
sur mon visage Jésus qui ont brouillé
les images et quand mes lèvres tous les
artistes qui se côtoient beaucoup on est
beaucoup dans les projets ils ont les
autres on se traîne tout au pantoum a
mis ensemble je veux pas je pense que ça
joue je pense que aussi je ressens pas
besoin d'aménage à Montréal parce que
justement c'est une communauté à Québec
qui est très vivante qui est présent il
y a plein de choses qui se font des
choses qui se créent
on ressent tant mieux si ça pendant
longtemps c'est comme nécessaire dans la
Montréal on dirait que c'était comme
mais maintenant c'est ben non c'est ça
se passe aussi ça se passe à Québec
Mathilde
[Musique]
à côté de toi
révélation Radio-Canada révélation aussi
au gala de la 10 tout jeune vous avez
d'ailleurs mis une vidéo sur Instagram
on pourra jouer du violon on dit souvent
que les parents ont une importance
capitale dans l'avenir d'un jeune dans
votre cas vos parents vous ont un
trimballé d'un festival de musique à un
autre la musique francophone et c'est
pour ça que vous avez commencé à chanter
en français
j'imagine moins très jeune on allait au
festival de chansons de la douceur ta
petite vallée aussi ou festival était
évidemment mais puis mes parents mes
parents écoutaient beaucoup mon père
surtout la musique beaucoup de jazz mais
beaucoup des artistes locaux puis des
artistes qui avaient aucun nom à ce
moment-là si je voudrais moi j'ai vu un
des premiers jours de ma réparateur
quand j'avais peut-être 10 ans
je me souviens beaucoup des femmes que
j'ai vu sur scène puis il y avait un
instrument si ça me donnait envie de
jouer un instrument ça me donne envie de
de arrêter juste violence et puis assez
court fallait que je prenne la Guite
puis ouais je pense que ça m'a influencé
beaucoup dans ma vision de femmes sur
cinq
il y a un an presque jour pour jour
sortait votre première album médium
plaisir alors un an plus tard cette pop
mélodieuse de complexée comme vous la
qualifiez comment la voyez-vous j'allais
écouter
ça faisait genre un an j'avais pas
écouté j'ai comme réécouté pour voir
comment je me sens encore par rapport à
ça c'est comme ça ça peut gênant mais et
puis André je le voyais plus avec
attendrissement puis j'étais comme un ok
ça représente une partie de ma vie c'est
mes 25 ans c'est c'est quelque chose de
d'intense on dirait que j'allais
chercher une émotion de d'adolescence
encore de désir de qui le focus ça se
passe pour que les choses se passent il
faut que
j'existe puis beaucoup d'affirmations
puis de colère dans cet album là aussi
[Musique]
je veux connaître un peu votre processus
de création semble-t-il que vous faites
du yogourt c'est quoi le Yogo pour créer
Ariane
qui est utilisé par beaucoup de monde
créer des chansons moi je fais mon yoga
plus en anglais ça c'est juste de
trouver des sonorités je te fais un
exemple c'est quand même
[Musique]
instinctivement qui m'amène après ça à
composer ma chanson non non non
je crois avec des mélodies qui sont plus
plus libre que ce que j'aurais fait
sinon
il y a quelque chose que piqué ma
curiosité sur votre site internet vous
vendez un jus de tarot
féministe
inclusif je sens en vous l'envie de me
tirer au tarole
les cheveux
le monde Tao d'où ça vient toute la
signification des cas les codes les
symboles puis je me suis quand même
intéressant à beaucoup beaucoup en
pandémie en fait ce truc comme quelque
chose à faire je fais que écrire un
album et les cartes c'est la tour
je sais pas qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
ta vie la tour c'est quand même les
fondations qui sont des fondations dans
quelque chose de ta vie par rapport à la
question que tu demandes qui sont pas
nécessairement c'est solides puis il va
peut-être avoir quelque chose de
bouleversant peut-être envie quelque
chose de très transformateur un
changement très intense mais c'est tout
le temps pour le mieux c'est bon la tour
ça amène tout à l'heure quelque chose de
plus positif de plus solide comme pour
refaire les fondations
[Musique]
les gens sont partis les gens ils sont
venus danser moi j'ai tant d'amour moi
aussi je t'aime j'avais tout compris que
j'aurais fait de rester